This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. To begin with, I have a new microphone. My last one broke. I feel like a few of you noticed it in a few of the last episodes. It was just like not doing its job. It wasn't working out for me. So I have this new one. I'm hoping that. I'm hoping that. from here on out there is less crackling. This is a funny story but I recently moved to
us and I accidentally moved underneath a international flight path. So yeah, that has been a factor in recordings recently whereby every time I try and sit down to do an episode, suddenly there is like a Boeing 707 flying over my ceiling. This microphone will hopefully stop that from filtering in because I feel like I want these conversations to be nice and peaceful and not interrupted by loud, obnoxious noises. So that is my first update. My second update is not an update. I'm just going to introduce what we're talking about today. Because today we're going to be discussing social media. Arguably, one of the biggest influences in our lives and I think society to emerge in the last 10 years. And what I really
want to do today is just have a discussion around how potentially harmful it has become, how little we tend to consider its impact on our health, on our beliefs, on our confidence, our self-esteem, our relationships, our friendships, even our careers to an extent. It just seems that social media has become this all-consuming influence in our lives. It's become so ubiquitous. that we don't really sit with the feeling and the thoughts and the psychology behind what that might be doing to us as a species. For so many of us, I think it's honestly so strange to imagine a world before social media became part of our lives.
You know, when we took pictures just for ourselves and our photo albums and we got our news from a newspaper and we picked our restaurants from the local guidebook rather than going on TikTok. It really is just completely changed our way of life. And I think for all the good that it has created, yes, we cannot deny the benefits. I think it's also time that we start talking about the societal, cultural and individual impact of our social media consumption and how it continues to dominate so much of what is important and priceless in our life. Our time, our self-esteem, our self-perception, our beliefs, our understanding of the world. We are really seeing in front of our eyes a complete shift in how.
we interact with each other, how we connect, how we date, how we establish our identity. And I don't think that we think about it nearly enough, nor do we take the time to identify when our social media usage is taking over and perhaps even making us sick in a way. It has made me sick mentally and then emotionally and finally, physically, it all kind of took its toll. And I think also when you come to that point of realization of like social media is ruining my mental health, it is making me so tired, so burnt out, it is turning me from a very optimistic person to a negative person. What do you do about that? How do you move forward? I feel like you have a diagnosis and there isn't necessarily a solution and you might be rolling your eyes right now
thinking, well, no one's forcing you to stay online. Like, just log off, just delete your accounts. But I also think that that is a lot easier said than done when we begin to really examine how addictive these platforms have been designed to be. There is intention behind capturing our attention. Let's not deny it. And also how you really, by choosing to not be present on social media, you kind of lock yourself out of a lot of possibility for interaction and to create,
friendships and to maintain friendships as well. The only way I can kind of describe this impact, the impact that this has had on me is that my brain has begun to feel very rotted, kind of from the inside out. Something has been getting rewired in my mind for a while. And I think there have been certain things that have just made me snap recently, certain experiences. There is this spotlight that seems to be constantly on us on social media. Anyone can find out anything.
Anyone can say anything that they want with really no repercussions. And that is just so strange. It is a huge difference from the environment, our brain and all of its neurological systems originally developed and evolved in one of limited mass group contact and small communities. You know, we aren't meant to have this much exposure to so many connections and be aware of so many people and have so many opportunities to judge and to be judged. Not only do I think it really skews what we see as normal and it promotes a sense of inadequacy, innate social comparison, whether that is to do with our bodies, our lives, how many
friends we have, our jobs, but I also think sometimes there is just too much information for our brains to process and we just experience an overload at times. everything just seems a little bit too serious and real online when it's not. Social media is not real. And I know it's insanely cliche to say that, but seriously, if you were to base your perception of reality on what you saw online, I would not want to live in that world. Okay, I know I'm sounding so pessimistic. But that has just been my experience, as everything in my life has gotten progressively better
and more stable and positive. The one aspect that remains a source of real frustration and sometimes pain is social media and all the secondary emotional states and reactions that it just seems to cause within me. And this has been especially exaggerated in the past three months. And I want to talk about it because how can we not talk about it? As people in our 20s, arguably this is the most formative decade of our adult lives. How much is social media impacting our own? psychology in unconscious ways because it is more than we are probably willing to acknowledge
or confront and what is the solution there? I don't think I'm one to complain about something whilst also not thinking about what comes next, what else is possible because social media is embedded in our lives in so many ways. I think it's kind of like alcohol or caffeine or processed sugar. It's addictive but we can find ways to be healthier and more sustainable about out consumption whilst also not completely limiting ourselves from some of the pleasure and some of the good that it does give us. To begin with, I'm going to kind of talk through my own experience and what's kind of led me to come to this revelation that social media is negatively impacting, perhaps ruining my mental health. I think that I never imagined that social media was going
to play such a huge role in my life. When I was, you know, younger in my teen years, I kind of stayed away from social media. I think I quit social media for like a year at one point. There's always kind of been this conscious part of me that's recognized that it is doing things to our brains that we are probably not fully aware of. And then I started this podcast. When I started the show, obviously, if you have been a loyal day one listener of which there are probably very few of you because it really was just like my parents and my friends and my grandma. I really just wanted to share my own experiences in my 20s.
I remember having this thought that this kind of project would be great for me to look back on in the future and have like a catalog, like an almost diary-like entries and voice memos of what I was experiencing at the time, like a journal. And then I just got so into it. I was so passionate about it. There was so much to talk about. people started following and now social media has become a component of my career as the podcast has become my full-time job which I'm so lucky to be able to say it's interesting that social media
becomes is hand in hand with that even though I'm doing something that it's completely separate from Instagram from TikTok you know I'm making a podcast I'm talking into a microphone about psychology and mental health and our 20s, there is this expectation that you need to have an online presence to kind of make your podcast, or I guess, like make your job and your career seem legitimate, right? Like, how can people know that you are doing good stuff and how can people find you if they can't find you through the platforms that they spend their most time on through Instagram, through TikTok, through X, through whatever it is? Social media is now, I think, equal part of my job as just, you know, content creation through an audio sense. I've even had
meetings where people will be like, well, we want you to improve your numbers or we need you to improve your online engagement before we can do a project with you. Even though like the project has nearly nothing to do with my Instagram presence or my follower account, like that's on an entirely different platform. I'm like a podcaster. I'm not as an influencer or a content creator. but it just goes to show that if you want to do anything that requires public acknowledgement for success, you have to kind of sell your soul a little bit to the algorithm. And it made me really obsessive. It made me not want to create for myself.
It made me want to create for others. And it kind of made me not enjoy the thing that I loved anymore, which is podcasting, which is storytelling and information sharing through audio. right like that was the main purpose from day one and it just felt like social media became a bigger beast than i perhaps wanted it to be on top of that let's just acknowledge that social media is such a time wasteer it is a absolute vacuum for our energy and our productive hours and i always think about this saying how you spend your days is how you spend your life and if you are spending five hours a day on your phone, on your screens.
That is sometimes a third of your waking hours, a third of your life, plugged into this constant hollow entertainment source. And I just think that we can't help it. It's addictive. It is a whole way of life in itself. And the thing that makes me really realize that is when I started contemplating how long I could spend without picking up my phone when I was working, how long could I spend off my phone before I started,
noticing the urge to automatically pick up and scroll for five minutes, 10 minutes, 20 minutes. It was like a 10 minute interruption system. You know, even if I'd left my phone in another room whilst I was working, I was like going on Facebook in like my Google search bar. Who uses Facebook anymore? Like there was nothing there that I needed to know. There was nothing there that was like a pressing information source. it was just a distraction.
It was just a source of a nice little dopamine hit. And it made me realize what am I actually getting from this habitual behavior and action of experiencing boredom or experiencing, I don't know, a bit of a rut or a mental rut and just picking up my phone immediately? This is a question I always ask myself and I think I've posed it on the podcast before but could you honestly tell me five things you've seen on social media today? Could you actually describe to me five TikToks that you've watched in the last week? And how did they improve your life?
What impression are these things really making? But more seriously, what is it contributing? How much of what you are observing for sometimes hours on hours a day, on an end, how much of that is actually permanent? you know what I mean? Like, could there is not, like those hours that you spend on social media are dead hours to me. They are dead hours. There is nothing that is sitting in your permanent long-term memory that is useful that you are gaining from scrolling.
I will say there are certainly good things. I do follow some creators that have had a really important impact on my life. There is this New Zealander creator called Riley Jay. She posts running content and that has really inspired me to like start running again and being really serious about it. Kielan Moncrief, she gives me a lot of things to contemplate my friend Sal and Al. They are just like such a positive influence online. They have great lifestyle tips, great saving tips. I take their advice.
Those are people that I think are really worth following and I can consciously remember things that they've said or questions that they've posed or content that they've posted that makes me stop and contemplate or change something about how I'm living my daily life. The community aspect is also brilliant. You know, I love seeing what my friends are doing who have moved to the other side of the world without having to wait for them to, you know, send me a postcard every three months. There is a lot of good, but it is this weird trade-off. The trade-off is, do you receive some of those perks and those benefits of community,
of inspiration if the trade-off is your time, which is one of the most precious things that we have? if the trade-off is your own, I guess, intelligence and your capacity to have original thoughts. The other element of this that I think we are speaking on a lot more is just the general negativity that is everywhere at the moment. I just started to see the world as a bad place. I would be scrolling social media, scrolling Instagram mainly, and I would go into the comment section of Reels. Don't do that. There is nothing good for you in there. There is literally nothing good for you in there. It is just like a terrible hellfire pit of everyone's worst thoughts
and worst feelings towards another human that they somehow feel they have the right to express openly on their platform. There was just so much hatred and troll accounts. And I think I began to anticipate what the comment section was going to say before I was even opening the comment section, before I was even posting a video of my own. You know, so organically, I began adopting the negativity of those who were already negative without them even needing to say anything, right? Like my mindset had shifted into their mindset to be protective or preventative to kind
of anticipate what they were going to say, but in, as a result, that made me a negative person. That is like, talk about indoctrination. That is just like a complete mind fucked me. You know, the hate that we have for each other is just like actually devastating. And those words have like a meaningful impact. As someone who has like an online presence and I hate saying that because I just feel like icky about it. But as someone who does have an online presence and it's something that obviously I'm grateful for, but it's kind of like the devil line. know, those words that people say that you might type out and be like, I'm just going to send that off,
that has a meaningful impact on someone. That can ruin their day. That can stick with them for months after you have already forgotten who they are, what they posted, what angered you. And there are just certain people who I see commenting on things where I'm like, I would hate to live in your brain. I would hate to be in there. That just seems so tiring. That just seems so exhausting, so negative, so unhappy that you have these thoughts that are so powerful in your head that you can't help but share them tangibly with others. And I just started to believe that having seen all these people and all this, you know, this like pattern of comments and troll accounts and whatnot, that the world was a bad place, that the world was negative, that people were becoming mean and cruel,
even if I can consciously step back and say, you know, these people don't know me, they will never know me. They have never spoken to me. They don't know what thoughts I have, internal feelings, what moral dilemmas I face, the guilt that I experience at times, the relationships that I have, the problems of my own that I'm trying to manage. I just think that social media gives you, like, the highlight reel, of course, but also gives you like just the film on top of the rest of life, right? like just the surface level of everyone's lives and everyone's feelings and everyone's feelings towards other people. It's also been so interesting comparing this to my boyfriend who has zero social media
presence. He has like an Instagram account he uses to follow his sisters and me and that's it. And it's really interesting because for the last 10 years, as we have, most of us have gotten sucked into basically a social media addiction or a social media dependence. He hasn't had that experience. And some of the things that I've noticed is that he experiences a lot less phomo, you know, a lot less of this fear of missing out. He is a lot more secure in his opinion of himself.
He is on his phone a whole lot less. He procrastinates less. He is able to focus for more extended periods of time. He has a greater attention span compared to me. It's almost like an observational experiment, right? It's like I've gone through the last 10, 12, 13 years with social media being part of my daily life, and he hasn't. And these are the kinds of people that we've turned out to be.
And I can't help but think that it really just truly comes down to how unplugged this man is. You know, his screen time is often less than like an hour or two hours each day. And that is just so much extra time. Like when you really think of it, that is like three. additional hours, sometimes four additional hours that he spends like actually looking at the world with his eyes upwards, whereas a lot of us are trapped in what feels like a bit of a cult, right? Like all my connections are built around it. Slowly my career is tied to it. It's at times where I get a lot of my news first. You know, if I open Instagram first thing in the morning,
there will be like the New York Times article, the variety article, the BBC, I. article, that will be the first thing that I see that is giving me like the headlines for the day. It's integral. There is no way of imagining what life would be without it. And yet everything is pointing to us needing to take a step back nowadays. We've gone too far. Anecdotally, I can see that we've gone too far. Scientifically, even legally on a global level, we can see that this has gone too far. There are some papers that have come out recently linking excessive social media usage, which is over two hours a day, I think a lot of us are hitting that. It's links that that's what they call excessive with poorer mental health outcomes. That means that you are more likely to experience
chronic stress, anxiety, depressive symptoms. And just recently, if you've been watching the news, meta, the company that obviously owns Instagram and Facebook, they had to like stand up before Congress and say yes, we are sorry. We know that our apps are used for me. misinformation. We know that our apps are used for cyberbullying that has caused people to take their own lives. We know that our apps have been designed to be addictive. We're sorry. Not that that really means much because they continue to do everything in their power to keep you hooked. Their paychecks really rely on your inability to say no to all the temptations that they are offering. And it's not to say that you have poor self-control or poor self-discipline. Like there are entire teams of neuroscientists
and data engineers and literally sometimes even psychologists who are helping them design systems that are addictive. You know, it is hijacking the systems by which we experience and kind of administer and process dopamine. Essentially, social media provides this endless amount of immediate information and immediate reward in the form of attention from others or bright, light, slashes, colors, information that you see as important. And so the brain rewires itself through this positive reinforcement,
either the pleasure that we receive, the dopamine that we receive from being entertained or from people's likes, people's views, people's retweets, people's reactions. And that we get these like short bursts of hits of dopamine that actually overall lower our sensitivity to not real dopamine, but sustained long term, kind of healthy dopamine is what I would call it. Essentially, we are receiving a lot of instant gratification from these apps, which means that we have a lot more of this neurotransmit dopamine available to us in our brain. And so our brain is like, well, we have all this, you know, we have this like drug, this happy chemical running around in our brain. Maybe we should shut off some of the receptors because we can't actually process all of this dopamine that's running between our neurons and passing through our synapses.
So basically what that means is that you have a lowered sensitivity. So over time, you're going to need more hits, more content, more attention, more time to receive that same level of pleasure that you were previously getting. That's before we even include the role of algorithms in the equation. My sister said something really interesting to me the other day. She said, if you download TikTok, you have about a two-week period before it gets really addictive. So that is, that two-week period is all you have. Because after that time has passed, that is how long it takes for the algorithm to learn what
you like and to start feeding you all the things and the themes and the topics that are really going to get your brain, specifically your brain, firing, that are really going to sit within a niche that had already existed beyond social media, that you obviously are going to be attentive towards. So I tested this out. I actually don't use TikTok anymore because like I said, it's addictive. It was really negatively impacting me. So I deleted TikTok about two months ago, maybe a little bit more now. But right at the start of when I did that, I red downloaded it and I couldn't get into my account. So I created a new account. And what started off as like just general content and like dancing videos and cooking videos and just things that everyone would kind of like within two weeks. I was
getting boxing content. I was getting Sydney restaurant recommendations. I was getting Taylor Swift updates. I was getting book talk reference, like things from book talk that were like exactly matching the books that I just read. I was getting travel recommendations for places that I'm not visiting for another three months. That is how good they are at capturing your attention by using your data to keep you plugged in. I know this sounds really like. suspicious and very like, I don't know, hoaxy and strange. But there is all this evidence for this occurring. And I think that as they begin to form a monopoly over every aspect of our lives, that monopoly also creates power. It creates power over our lives. And I don't think that
that is doing more good than harm, at least in my own personal life. So what do we actually do about that, right? Like it's one thing to complain about something. But I think, that we also need solutions. I'm going to talk about all of that and so much more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers and other health and fitness experts and more. to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all. about crack in the 80s.
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all. about crack in the 80s.
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the. iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kier Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose.
On my new podcast, learn the whole. Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
在我的新播客中，了解那些惨痛的教训。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。森德女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们会发现一个令人不安的规律。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨戴尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. All righty. So in addressing how social media is impacting our lives and what we can do about it, I want to talk about three aspects. What we can do about social media as a source of negativity, what we can do about social media as a time waster and what we can do about social media as a source of inadequacy and social comparison. So starting at the top, what can we do about social media as a source of negativity? Number one, I would say, make sure that you are curating an online environment that makes you feel comfortable.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在 Iheart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。好了。所以在探讨社交媒体如何影响我们的生活以及我们能做些什么时，我想从三个方面来谈谈。我们可以对作为负面情绪来源的社交媒体做些什么，我们可以对作为时间浪费者的社交媒体做些什么，以及我们可以对作为自卑感和社交比较来源的社交媒体做些什么。所以从头开始，我们可以对作为负面情绪来源的社交媒体做些什么？第一点，我想说，确保你正在精心打造一个让你感到舒适的网络环境。
If you notice that there is certain topics, certain videos that really make you feel pretty awful, whether that is, I don't know, body content, gym content, online, trolling content, celebrity content that is just like overtly negative, set boundaries for yourself that essentially instruct you when it's time to unfollow those accounts or restrict your access. to them. Something that I like to do is when I see something where I'm like, this is immediately making me frustrated and angry. And I know that that is like part of the technique to keep me attached is like, I'm going to disagree with this. So I'm going to become more engaged in what other people are saying. I immediately press like not interested. I scroll. I like find the little settings area and
如果你注意到某些话题、某些视频真的让你感觉很不舒服，无论是，我不知道，身材内容、健身内容、网络骂战内容、名人内容，这些内容简直就是彻头彻尾的负面信息，那就为自己设定一些界限，这些界限本质上是在告诉你什么时候该取消关注这些账户，或者限制你对它们的访问。我喜欢做的一件事是，当我看到让我立刻感到沮丧和愤怒的内容时，我知道这也是让我离不开它的一部分技巧，那就是——我要反驳这个观点。所以我将更多地参与到其他人所说的话中。我立刻点击“不感兴趣”。我滑动屏幕。我找到小设置区域，然后
I go not interested. Like don't show me content from this person again. Just in order to kind of limit my sense that the world is a bad place by constantly seeing content from people who are pretty adamant on making it seem that way. And the other thing that I say is where you see negativity, leave positivity. Interrupt the thought process that is making you see everything as terrible by being the good that you want to kind of see in the world. So I've been doing this recently. Sometimes I'll watch a video and I'll be like, all right, I just know what the comment section is going to look like here. I just know. I know that if it's a woman at the gym
点击“不感兴趣”。比如不要再向我推荐这个人的内容。这只是为了通过不断看到那些坚决要把世界描绘成糟糕地方的人的内容，来限制我对世界是一个糟糕地方的感觉。我要说的另一件事是，你在哪里看到负面情绪，就在哪里留下正能量。通过成为你想在世界上看到的善良，来打断那个让你把一切都看作糟糕事物的思维过程。所以我最近一直在这样做。有时我会看一个视频，然后我会想：好吧，我只知道这里的评论区会是什么样子。我就是知道。我知道如果是一个在健身房的女性
who doesn't look like most women at the gym, there are going to be thousands of men in the comment section just like absolutely abusing her and being so cruel. So I'm going to make a conscious decision to like leave a positive comment on this video. Even though I don't normally like to, you know, I'm kind of like a prowler. Like even though I don't normally like to like leave comments on things because I don't know. It just feels strange. I always try and do it with those videos, right?
她看起来不像健身房里的大多数女性，评论区就会有成千上万的男性对她进行绝对的辱骂和残酷的攻击。所以我将做一个有意识的决定，在这个视频下留下一条积极的评论。尽管我通常不喜欢，你知道的，我有点像个潜水者。就像，尽管我通常不喜欢在事情下面留评论，因为我不知道。这感觉很奇怪。我总是试图在那些视频中这样做，对吧？
The same thing I saw this video of this girl the other day who was like, can you notice my biggest insecurity? Like, no, you can't. So, you know, move on with your life. And everyone in the comment section was like, oh, I can notice it. It's this. It's that. It's your skin.
同样的事情，我前几天看到这个女孩的视频，她说：“你能看出我最大的容貌焦虑吗？”不，你不能。所以，你知道，过好你自己的生活吧。而评论区的所有人都说：“哦，我能看出来。是这个。是那个。是你的皮肤。”
It's your face. It's your body. What the heck? And so I just left a nice comment. And I think that it just shows, it kind of like rewires your thought process whereby instead of thinking like everyone is out there to be mean. It's like, no, that's not true because I'm not out here. be mean. And there must be other people who are in the same boat. And you see it, people start
是你的脸。是你的身材。搞什么鬼？所以我只是留下了一个友好的评论。我认为这表明，它有点像重塑了你的思维过程，让你不再认为每个人都在外面怀有恶意。而是想：不，这不是真的，因为我没有在外面怀有恶意。而且肯定还有其他人也处于同样的处境。你看到了，人们开始
engaging with your comments because they're looking for something in that comment section that's going to actually match what they feel, which is that this person is doing an amazing job. This person is beautiful. This person is kind. This person does not deserve criticism. Let's, you know, elevate those voices that are seeking to promote a more kind, compassionate, empathetic, mindset on these platforms whereby, you know, the algorithm does promote negativity and troll accounts above everything else because they capture our attention. Next, in order to kind of address social media as a time waste of for yourself, I think there are a few things that you need to do.
参与你的评论，因为他们在评论区寻找能够真正符合他们感受的东西，那就是这个女孩做得非常好。这个人很美。这个人很善良。这个人不值得受到批评。让我们，你知道的，提升那些试图在这些平台上推崇更善良、更有同情心、更有共情力的心态的声音，在这个平台上，你知道的，算法确实把负面情绪和水军账号推到了所有事情之上，因为它们抓住了我们的注意力。接下来，为了解决社交媒体对你时间的浪费，我认为有几件事你需要做。
firstly, try and break that urge to pick up your phone whenever you are feeling bored, lonely, distracted, frustrated, see how long you can hold off. See how long you can ignore or suppress that immediate need to satisfy an itch and urge a desire. When you do that, you're experiencing delayed gratification. We talked about this before. Essentially what you're doing, is saying to your brain, like, hey, I actually have a conscious, a conscious voice here. I'm a conscious decider, a conscious actor when it comes to the urges that you send my way. I don't have to act on them. I'm making it a choice based on what I think is best. I don't have to do what you say I need to do. You know, it's not like an urge or it's not like a craving for
首先，试着打破那种每当你感到孤独、无聊、分心、沮丧时就想拿起手机的冲动，看看你能坚持多久。看看你能忽略或压抑这种想要立刻满足某种渴望、冲动和欲望的急切心理多久。当你这样做时，你正在体验延迟满足。我们之前讨论过这个。本质上你在做的是，对你的大脑说：嘿，我在这里其实有一个意识，一个有意识的声音。当面对你向我发送的冲动时，我是一个有意识的决定者，一个有意识的行动者。我没有必要根据它们采取行动。我根据我认为最好的是做出选择。我不需要做你告诉我需要做的事。你知道的，这不像是一种对
water or a craving for food or for sleep or for safety. It's just a craving. for dopamine, it's a craving for distraction, that can be ignored and you can hold yourself back from fulfilling that and see how long you can do it for. Is it five minutes? Is it for 10? Is it for an hour? And slowly train your brain and train yourself to recognize that you don't always have to give in to what you immediately want. It's also about identifying behaviors that cause you to look for that quick boost, right? Is it when you are bored? Is it when you are lonely, like we said before? I think that knowing what the root kind of trigger is for this seeking behavior, this social media seeking behavior, is really important in limiting it. This is where the idea of a dopamine
水的渴望，或者对食物或睡眠或安全的渴望。这只是一种对多巴胺的渴望，是一种对分心的渴望，这是可以被忽略的，你可以阻止自己去满足它，看看你能坚持多久。是五分钟？是十分钟？是一个小时？并慢慢训练你的大脑，训练你自己去认识到，你不必总是向你立即想要的东西妥协。这也关乎识别那些导致你寻找这种快速刺激的行为，对吧？是因为你无聊吗？是因为你感到孤独吗，就像我们之前说的？我认为了解这种寻求行为、这种寻求社交媒体行为的根本触发因素是什么，对于限制它是非常重要的。这就是多巴胺
detox often comes in detox meaning you know just just an opportunity to kind of cleanse your body of a bad thing in this case excessive social media usage the premise of a dopamine detox is that you reduce your brain sensitivity to dopamine by removing that kind of like removing a behavior or a substance or stimuli or an experience for a period of time so that that your brain gets used to not having it. Ideally, by the end of the detox, you feel more centered, you feel more balanced, less affected by your usual dopamine triggers. However, I do think that we should be a little bit suspicious of this. I do think it's important to take time away, to step back to provide your mind and your brain with a place for clarity and for peace that is
戒断这个概念通常出现的地方，戒断的意思是，你知道的，这只是一个洗涤你体内不良事物的机会，在这种情况下就是过度使用社交媒体。多巴胺戒断的前提是，你通过移除某种行为、物质、刺激或体验一段时间，来降低你大脑对多巴胺的敏感度，这样你的大脑就会习惯没有它的生活。理想情况下，在戒断结束时，你会感到更加集中，更加平衡，更少受到日常多巴胺触发因素的影响。然而，我确实认为我们应该对这一点保持一点怀疑。我确实认为抽时间远离，退一步，为你的思想和大脑提供一个获得清晰和宁静的空间是很重要的，这个空间
not constantly interrupted by loud music and dancing and controversy. I think a more accurate description though of dopamine detox is actually just a period of abstinence or unplugging from the world, which just serves to minimize distraction and reliance to kind of show you that you can live without this thing even if it's hard, right? You are essentially battling a system that wants to keep you addicted and plugged in. And I think it's important to sometimes show ourselves that we can live without that, that the world would not end, that you can take a step back and it might feel hard, it might feel difficult, but that very, the very reality that it feels difficult and that it kind of feels painful in a way, feels like you're in a state of withdrawal. The very fact that it feels
不会不断被嘈杂的音乐、舞蹈和争议所打断。不过，我认为对多巴胺戒断更准确的描述其实只是一段禁欲或与世界断连的时期，这只是为了减少干扰和依赖，向你证明即使过程艰难，你也能没有这个东西生活，对吧？你本质上是在与一个想要让你上瘾并保持连线的系统作斗争。我认为有时向自己展示我们可以没有那个东西生活是很重要的，世界不会毁灭，你可以退一步，虽然这可能会让人感觉艰难，可能会让人感觉困难，但它感觉困难的这个事实，以及它在某种程度上让人感觉痛苦的事实，感觉就像你处于戒断状态一样。这种感觉的
like that is probably a sign that you needed to do it, that there was something there that was borderline unhealthy, borderline dependent. Finally, let's address social media as a form of inadequacy and social comparison. The very nature of social media in that it keeps us interconnected means that we have thousands if not millions of opportunities at any time of the day to compare ourselves on any number of factors. We can compare our bodies to people we see on our for you page. We can compare our careers on LinkedIn.
事实可能是一个信号，表明你需要这么做，表明那里有些东西已经接近不健康、接近依赖了。最后，让我们来谈谈作为不安全感和社交比较形式的社交媒体。社交媒体的本质在于它使我们保持互联，这意味着我们在一天中的任何时候都有成千上万甚至数百万次机会在无数因素上将自己进行比较。我们可以将自己的身材与在“为你推荐”页面上看到的人进行比较。我们可以在领英上比较我们的职业。
We can compare how many friends we have to TikToks that we see of people who seemingly have it all. how fashionable we are, how happy we are. Like there are just so many opportunities to look at someone else's life and feel like you are lacking and for that sense of lacking, for that sense of having less, to impact how you enjoy your reality. I just want you to remind yourself, this is not real. Social media is not real.
我们可以把拥有的朋友数量和TikTok上那些看起来拥有一切的人进行对比，比如我们有多时尚，我们有多快乐。就像有太多机会去看看别人的生活，觉得自己有所欠缺，而这种欠缺感、这种拥有较少的感觉，会影响你享受现实的方式。我只想提醒大家，这不是真的。社交媒体不是真的。
anyone can present or say anything without it being true, without it being accurate. I think about my own social media presence, right? You know, so many of those photos that I posted from like ages ago, or they're from like spread out over weeks, or they're from like the one day that week that I like looked nice. I'm recording this podcast right now and I am wearing a wolf shirt, my hair is up in a bun, I look foul. I'm not wearing pants, I will say.
任何人都可以展示或说出任何事情，而这些事情不一定是真的，也不一定是准确的。我想到了我自己的社交媒体形象，对吧？你知道，我发布的许多照片都是很久以前的，或者是几周内分散拍摄的，又或者是那一周里我看起来状态不错的那一天拍的。我正在录制这个播客，身上穿着一件狼图案的衬衫，头发扎成了一个丸子头，我看起来糟透了。顺便说一句，我没穿裤子。
that's just a little secret. Like, I'm not going to post this on social media, but people, I got this comment from someone the other day being like, oh my God, I'm just like, so jealous of you and how many friends you have. And I was like, that is not true. Like, that is, this is just an impression. This is your perspective. I still am someone who is like deeply lonely at times
这只是个小秘密。比如，我不会把这个发到社交媒体上，但前几天有人给我留言说，天哪，我真的很嫉妒你，嫉妒你有那么多朋友。当时我就想，这根本不是真的。这只是一个印象，这是你的视角。我其实还是一个有时会感到极度孤独的人，
and who deeply struggles with the sense of permanency around my friendships. I am still someone who struggles with how I see my body in comparison to other people. but you can choose to kind of curate what that looks like for people. It's not real. It's not real. I also think that a really great way to counteract this sense that it is, is to, or not even just the sense that it is real, but the sense that what other people are showing you is important for your life,
而且在我的友谊中，我一直在与那种缺乏长久稳定感的情绪作斗争。与其他人相比，我仍然在如何看待自己的身材方面感到挣扎。但你可以选择为人们呈现出什么样貌。这不是真的。这不是真的。我还认为，对抗这种虚幻感的一个绝佳方法——或者说不仅仅是认识到它是虚幻的，而是认识到别人向你展示的东西对你的生活有多重要——
is to spend time in nature. We know that it's so healing to be outdoors, to touch and feel and smell and see something that matters, and to see something that is real and that you can confirm is real. I think it really brings you back to reality. It's a bit of a perspective shift so often. Like we get stuck in this like the space between our mind and our screen. And that seems like the only thing that matters.
就是花时间在大自然中。我们知道，走到户外去触摸、去感受、去闻、去看到真正有意义的事物，看到真实且能被证实的事物，是极具治愈效果的。我认为这确实能把你拉回现实。这通常是一种视角上的转变。我们常常陷入思维和屏幕之间的空间，并觉得那是唯一重要的事情。
And it seems like it is a lot more important than it is when going outside and being like, there is a whole world outside of this. And nobody cares about what that person is saying. Nobody cares about what that person is doing. Like they may do. but is it really impacting like all the other things that are going on in the world that require our attention? Probably not.
相比于走到户外去发现“外面还有一个广阔的世界，而且没有人会在乎那个人在说什么，没有人会在乎那个人在做什么”，它似乎要重要得多。也许他们在乎，但这真的会影响到世界上其他需要我们关注的事情吗？可能不会。
You know, it's just this, I think, an important practice to pull yourself out of phantom reality from time to time, either through what we said was a dopamine detox or through just making a conscious decision to like put yourself in a situation where you were completely unplugged, outdoors, enjoying fresh air, enjoying the ocean, enjoying, enjoying, the smells, the sights, the beauty of nature and of your surroundings. With the social comparison thing, I will say one more thing on that. Everyone who you are comparing yourself to is also comparing themselves to somebody else. It is this whole continuous cycle and loop of comparison.
你知道，我认为这是一种重要的实践，能让你不时地把心智从虚幻的现实中拉出来，无论是通过我们之前所说的多巴胺排毒，还是通过做一个有意识的决定：让自己完全处于不联网的状态中，去到户外，享受新鲜空气，享受大海，享受大自然和周围环境的气味、景色以及美景。关于社会比较这件事，我还要多说一点。每一个你正在与之比较的人，其实也在和别人比较。这是一个完整且持续的比较循环。
I don't think anybody is safe from it. There is not a single person out there who, I would say, is active on social media and feels great about themselves all the time. They just like to give the impression that they are. But there are so many sources for us to feel dissatisfied and nobody is immune to that. So you are only human, you are fallible, we are all insecure, we are all battling something behind the guys of our feed and what we post. Make sure that that, you don't lose sight of that. Make sure that you are aware of the ways in which, you know, everything is not as it seems, especially on platforms where there is an incentive to make things look better,
我认为没有人能独善其身。没有一个人可以说他在社交媒体上活跃，并且无时无刻不对自己感觉良好。他们只是喜欢给人留下这样的印象。但有太多的源头让我们感到不满，没有人能对此免疫。所以你只是凡人，你也会犯错，我们都缺乏安全感，我们在动态和发布的背后都在与某些东西搏击。确保你不要忽视这一点。确保你意识到，事物并非表面看起来的那样，尤其是在那些有动机让事情看起来更美好的平台上，
when there is an incentive to post content that is aesthetic because it will be high performing, because it will attract people, because it will get their attention because that is what they want, because that is a life that someone is trying to sell them. All right, I think that that is enough ranting for me today, and I acknowledge that it was a rant. Obviously, I think that this has been something on my,
当发布具有美感的、能够获得高浏览量、能够吸引人、能够获得关注的内容存在激励时，因为那是他们想要的，因为那是某人试图推销给别人的生活。好了，我想我今天的长篇大论就到这里了，我也承认这只是一场牢骚。显然，我认为这已经占据了我的心头，
my mind for some time and if you follow me on Instagram you'll see that I've just put some things in place to make my online environment safer, some online boundaries, some online rules. It's important to talk about. You know, it is a really big factor in influence. And if you can relate to this, to any aspect of this, I believe in you. I'm proud of you for at least getting this far where you're having like conscious thoughts around something in your life that might be unhealthy, that being social media and I get that it's really hard. I get that it's really addictive and that you can really want to, you know that one thing is the right thing, right? You know that there is something that you need to do for your health but you just can't bring yourself to do it. It's not all your fault.
有一段时间了，如果你在Instagram上关注我，你会发现我刚刚采取了一些措施来让我的网络环境更安全，设定了一些网络边界和网络规则。谈论这些很重要。你知道，这是产生影响的一个非常大的因素。如果你能与此产生共鸣，与其中的任何方面产生共鸣，我相信你。我为你感到骄傲，因为你至少走到了这一步，开始对你生活中可能不健康的事情（也就是社交媒体）产生有意识的想法，我明白这真的很难。我明白这真的很让人上瘾，你知道某件事是正确的一对吧，你知道有些事你需要为了健康去做，但你就是无法强迫自己去做。这并不能全怪你。
The keys are deliberately made to be addictive. All so many aspects of our lives are embedded in social media right now. Our careers, our social lives, our work. So I'm rooting for you. We're in it together, I promise. And just a reminder to be kind to people. Be kind. If you see negativity, leave positivity. If you want to say something, don't. You're going to feel better anyways if you don't say it. If you don't ruin somebody's day, you never know the sting that words leave. And I think that's where I'm going to leave it. I think that is a great final message. Be kind to others and be really kind to yourself as well because you deserve to be happy and to be gentle with yourself and to create an environment whether that is online or in your real life that doesn't leave you feeling
这些按键被刻意设计成让人上瘾的。我们生活的方方面面现在都嵌入了社交媒体。我们的职业、我们的社交生活、我们的工作。所以我支持你。我们风雨同舟，我保证。顺便提醒大家要善待他人。保持善良。如果你看到消极情绪，就留下积极情绪。如果你想说些什么，那就别说。如果你不说出来，你会感觉更好。如果你没有毁掉某人的一天，你永远不会知道言语留下的刺痛感。我想我就讲到这里吧。我认为这是一个很好的最终信息。善待他人，也真正地善待自己，因为你值得拥有快乐，值得对自己温柔以待，值得创造一个环境——无论是线上还是现实生活中——不会让你对这个世界感到
shit about the world and shit about yourself. So thank you so much for listening. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening, IA Radio app, I don't know what the other ones are, wherever you are in the world. Please feel free to also send me some episode suggestions. I love hearing from you. We can't always do them all, but it is great to hear what other people in their 20s are going through and to then have the opportunity to look into the psychology of those things. It is so much fun. And I also just love hearing from you. I love hearing from people all over the world who are, you know, listening to this content and relating to it makes a lot of our experiences feel quite universal,
对世界感到糟糕，对自己感到糟糕。非常感谢大家的收听。和往常一样，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你正在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。iHeart Radio应用程序，我不知道还有哪些其他的，无论你身在世界何处。请随时给我发送一些关于节目的建议。我喜欢听你们的反馈。我们不可能总是采纳所有建议，但听到20多岁的人正在经历什么，然后有机会深入探讨这些事情背后的心理学，真的是太棒了。这太有趣了。我也很喜欢听你们的分享。听到来自世界各地的人们都在收听这些内容并产生共鸣，让我们的许多经历感觉非常普遍，
or makes me feel less alone. You can also follow me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. I get the irony of me saying that after a social media episode, but I actually no longer am like actively running that account. So feel free to go and see what's going on there. I don't really know. Just kidding, I do. But it would be great to, you know, build out nice, like actual positive corner of the community,
或者让我觉得不那么孤单。你也可以在Instagram上关注我，账号是That Psychology Podcast。我明白在一个关于社交媒体的节目之后说这句话有点讽刺，但我实际上已经不再积极运营那个账号了。所以大家可以去看看那里发生了什么。我其实也不知道。开个玩笑，我其实知道。不过，能建立一个美好且真正积极的社区角落，
of the social media community. And as always, we will be back next week with another episode. until then, stay safe and be kind to yourself. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
社交媒体社区的角落，那将是极好的。和往常一样，我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。在此之前，请注意安全，善待自己。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
我将为您剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。这就是数字2%。
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我会成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you got your podcast. I got you. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。我懂你。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。
84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着通过我们的朋友、喜剧同仁和最喜欢的作家，来理解我们是如何熬过那段日子的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Eye Heart Ready app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那确实是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，
that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard. the way on the iHeart radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这些对话在其他地方真的不太安全能进行，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你非得这么做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一个iHeart播客，保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。